>> Greg: BERNIE SANDERS
CAMPAIGN MANAGER IS DENYING LIZ
WARREN'S CLAIM THAT BERNIE SAID
A WOMAN COULDN'T WIN A PRESIDENC
A WOMAN COULDN'T WIN A PRESIDEN,
A WOMAN COULDN'T WIN A PRESIDENT
A WOMAN COULDN'T WIN A PRESIDENE
A WOMAN COULDN'T WIN A PRESIDENN
HE BLAMED TRUMP.
>> THIS IS A STORY THAT WAS
OBVIOUSLY PUT OUT BY OWN NAME TO
FOLKS HE WAS INVITED TO
SENATOR WARREN'S HOUSE, SHE TOLD
HIM SHE WAS RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT.
ANYONE SAYING A WOMAN COULDN'T
WIN, IT MAKES NO SENSE.
HILLARY CLINTON WON 300 MILLION
MORE VOTES THAN DONALD TRUMP.
CLEARLY BERNIE SANDERS DID NOT
SAY A WOMAN COULD NOT WIN.
IT WAS A DISCUSSION BY TRUMP,
MISOGYNY, SEXISM AND POLITICS
AND THE DIFFICULTY OF RUNNING IN
THE ERA OF TRUMP FOR WOMEN, THE
SPECIAL CHALLENGES WOMEN FACE IN
THE ERA OF TRUMP.
THOSE CONVERSATIONS CAN
SOMETIMES GET MISCONSTRUED.
>> Greg: THE THREE STEPS OF
IDENTITY POLITICS, THE HOKEY
POKEY OF THE LEFT.
FIRST FOCUS ON SKIN COLOR OR
GENDER BEARD SECOND, ALWAYS USE
THE WORST INTERPRETATION OF A
PERSON'S INTENT.
IF SOMEONE SAYS THEY DON'T EAT
BROWN M&MS THEY MUST BE RACIST.
MISCONSTRUE AND DENY GOOD FAITH.
THIRD, FIND COMMON GROUND BY
BLAMING TRUMP BECAUSE YOU KNOW
HE IS A EVIL DESPITE DOING MORE
FOR MINORITIES THAN THE CLOWNS
RUNNING AGAINST HIM LIKE
BERNIE SANDERS.
IT IS HARD NOT TO LOVE THIS,
WATCH THE CROCODILE THAT IS
IDENTITY POLITICS EAT THE PARTY
THAT FED IT FOR YEARS, EACH AND
NOW BUYS FOR THE MOST OPPRESSED.
BUT SINCE THEY ALREADY SMEARED
HALF THE COUNTRY THE ONLY PEOPLE
LEFT TO DESTROY OUR THEMSELVES.
IT'S NOT A FIGHT BETWEEN LEFT
AND RIGHT BUT LIBS WHO NOW SEE
THERE IS NO ESCAPE FROM THEIR
MINDLESS, ANGRY PEERS.
LOOK AT CORY BOOKER.
STANFORD GRAD, YALE LAW,
PRO-SCHOOL CHOICE IN THE CITY
WERE DEMOCRATS DEMOLISHED PUBLIC
EDUCATION, BUT EVEN IN HIS EXIT
HE MADE IT ABOUT IDENTITY.
THEY DIDN'T LOSE CORY BOOKER.
THEY LOST THE BLACK GUY APPEARED
AT SOME POINT, THE DEMS MUST
REALIZE AMERICA IS ABOUT
UNITY, NOT DIFFERENCE.
TRUMP GOT THAT.
THE ONLY WAY TO BEAT HIM AS FOR
HIS OPPONENTS TO DO THE SAME
THING, WHICH MEANS FOUR MORE
YEARS OF TRUMP.
LET'S DO A LITTLE QUIZ --
>> Juan: WAIT A MINUTE, FOUR
MORE YEARS OF TRUMP?
CAN I LEAVE NOW?
>> Greg: DON'T MOVE TO
NEW ZEALAND, WE LOVE YOU.
IF THIS IS A HE SAID, SHE SAID,
OR THEY SAID, LET'S SAY THEY
SAID JUST SO THEY WON'T GET MAD.
WHO IS MORE TRUSTWORTHY?
BERNIE SANDERS OR LIZ, WHO LIED
ABOUT BEING CHEROKEE, TRY TO
COVER UP WITH A DNA TEST WHICH
CLAIMS SHE WAS FIRED BY BEING
PREGNANT, LIED ABOUT HELPING
COMPANIES ESCAPE LIABILITIES.
SANDERS IS NOT A LIAR.
SHE LIED.
SHE CANNOT BE THE NOMINEE
BECAUSE HOW COULD SHE PLAY THE
CHARACTER ROLE WITH A TRUMP
QUESTION MARCO AFTER CHARACTER.
SHE IS A SCHEMING, LYING LIAR.
>> Juan: MR. TRUMP --
>> Greg: NO, THAT WAS
MR. SANDERS.
SHE'S LYING!
>> Juan: IT'S NOT NICE TO
BRING IT UP BUT BERNIE HAS HAD
SOME TROUBLE, CLAIMS OF HOW
WOMEN WERE TREATED IN HIS OWN
CAMPAIGN THAT YOU'VE GOT TO
ANSWER FOR SO I DON'T KNOW.
BUT I DO THINK WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THESE TWO, I WOULD SAY THAT YOU
COULD SEE BOTH SIDES BEING
ABSOLUTELY TRUE.
THAT HE WAS SAYING TO HER TRUMP
IS A BULLY, SEXIST, IT'S GOT TO
BE HARD FOR A WOMAN TO BEAT HIM,
AND LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENED WITH
HILLARY LAST TIME.
OR YOU COULD HAVE HER SAYING,
WHAT I'M HEARING YOU TELL ME,
MR. SANDERS, IS THAT A WOMAN
CAN'T BEAT DONALD TRUMP.
IF THAT IS THE CASE -- AND BY
THE WAY, THAT IS A HUGE
CONVERSATION RIGHT NOW.
I MEAN, THERE'S ONLY TWO WOMEN
ON THE DEBATE STAGE TONIGHT.
WARREN AND AMY KLOBUCHAR.
>> Greg: MUCH MORE QUALIFIED,
WITHOUT QUESTION.
>> Juan: BUT I THINK WHEN YOU
STOP AND THINK ABOUT IT, THE
CONVERSATION GOES WELL, WHO CAN
BEAT DONALD TRUMP IF YOU ARE A
DEMOCRAT?
WOULD YOU TRUST A MAN, WOULD YOU
TRUST IS MADE ON?
WOULD YOU TRUST A BLACK PERSON?
CORY BOOKER?
>> Greg: OBAMA WAS PRESIDENT
TWICE PRESIDENT TWICE.
>> Juan: BUT THESE GUYS AREN'T
APPARENTLY IN THE SAME CATEGORY.
RUNNING AGAINST DONALD TRUMP,
YOU ARE LOOKING AT WINNING BACK
WHITE MALES IN SWING STATES.
HOW DO YOU APPEAL TO THEM
CUSTOMER WHO APPEALS TO THEM?
LOTS OF DEMOCRATS, SOME MIGHT
SAY OUT OF FEAR RATHER THAN
HOPEFULNESS, ARE CONCERNED THAT
ANYBODY BUT A WHITE MALE IS
GOING TO HAVE A MORE DIFFICULT
TIME.
>> Jesse: I CAN'T BELIEVE I'M
AGREEING WITH EVERYTHING HE JUST
SAID.
SHE HAD TO ANNOUNCE, AND OUT OF
RESPECT FOR SANDERS, THEY HAD TO
HAVE A MEETING AND SHE HAS TO
SAY, BERNIE, I'M RUNNING,
BECAUSE HE WON MEGA OF VOTES
LAST TIME.
IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO DO.
HE MAYBE WAS A LITTLE OFFENDED.
SHE IS IN HIS LAY IN LITTLE BIT.
THIS WAS HIS TURN, AND THEY
START TALKING Xs AND Os.
DIDN'T HAVE A GREAT SUCCESS
RUNNING HILLARY AGAINST TRUMP
LAST TIME.
TRUMP MAY MATCH UP BETTER
AGAINST A WOMAN FOR A CERTAIN
REASON, WE DON'T KNOW WHAT IT I
IS.
TALKING SHOP, TALKING POLITICS,
AND SHE MAY BE INTERPRETED THAT
AS A SEXIST COMMENT.
>> Greg: I DOUBT IT.
SHE IS A LIAR.
>> Jesse: I HAVE TO AGREE WITH
JUAN, BUT BERNIE HAS TO
EXTRICATE HIMSELF FROM THIS
SMOOTHLY.
BECAUSE IF SHE DOES GET THE
NOMINATION AND HE IS GOING TO
NEED THESE WARREN VOTES.
IN THE MEANTIME,
ELIZABETH WARREN, I DON'T KNOW
HOW SHE GETS ON THE TICKET BUT
IF SHE DOES, SHE CAN'T TEE OFF
BERNIE BURROUGHS BECAUSE BERNIE
BROS, ONLY 10% OF THEM LAST TIME
VOTED FOR TRUMP, SO SHE CAN'T
ANTAGONIZE HIS VOTERS TOO MUCH
BECAUSE SHE IS GOING TO NEED
THAT.
>> Greg: THE OTHER THING THAT
BUGS ME IS THAT THIS WAS IN A
PRIVATE MEETING.
SHE IS A LYING THINK!
>> Juan: WHAT IS THAT CUSTOMER
ASKED MARK >> Greg: YOU KNOW,
LIKE A RAT
>> Dana: I DON'T KNOW IF HE
REALLY SAID IT THAT WAY BUT IF
YOU ARE PRONE TO TAKE OFFENSE
ABOUT SOMETHING, YOU WILL HEAR
PEOPLE OFFENDING YOU EVERYWHERE
YOU LOOK.
AND SOMETIMES PEOPLE LIKE
ELIZABETH WARREN, THAT HAPPENS
TO, NOBODY SAW IT BUT ON SUNDAY,
RAHM EMANUEL, FORMER CHIEF OF
STAFF COME EVERY FEW MONTHS HE
WRITES AN OP-ED BEGGING THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY TO ABANDON
IDENTITY POLITICS.
NOBODY IS LISTENING TO THAT AS
WELL, BUT I THOUGHT ANOTHER
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION ALUM SAID
THAT HE THINKS THAT BECAUSE OF
WHAT WARREN DID WITH THIS LEAK
OF THE PRIVATE CONVERSATION,
THAT NATIVE AMERICAN ANCESTRY IS
NOT FAIR GAME FOR BERNIE.
>> Greg: THERE YOU GO.
BECAUSE SHE IS SAYING THESE
THINGS --
>> Jesse: HE DIDN'T GO AFTER
HILLARY'S EMAILS, I DON'T THINK
WE'LL GO AFTER THIS.
>> Greg: A LOT OF PROBLEMS
WITH WARREN, SHE CAN'T BE
TRUSTED.
SHE IS A LIAR.
>> Emily: OF THREE PROBLEMS
WITH HER PULLING THIS STUNT.
NUMBER ONE, IT WAS TOO
INFLAMMATORY BECAUSE THE REALITY
OF THAT SITUATION IS PROBABLY
ACTUALLY HOW YOU DESCRIBED,
WHICH IS A REALITY,
Xs AND Os CONVERSATION,
WHERE HE MAY BE SAID, I'M NOT
SURE, YOUR SPITBALL AND,
DISCUSSING, AND SHE TURNS AROUND
AND RAT HIM OUT AND IT IS
OBVIOUS WITH IT, SO WE THINK OF
HER AS DESPERATE.
AND B, IT'S QUITE POSSIBLE HIM
DENYING IT.
I DIDN'T SAY A WOMAN COULDN'T
WIN.
TULSI GABBARD CAME OUT TODAY,
SHE SAID, I HAD THAT SAME CANDID
CONVERSATION WITH BERNIE AND HE
SHOWED ME THE GREATEST RESPECT
AND ENCOURAGEMENT THAT HE IS
KNOWN FOR.
I THINK HE AND HIS CAMP, THAT
PLAUSIBLE DENIABILITY.
HE IS NOT THE KIND OF GUY THAT
WILL GO, HE'LL KNOW WHAT WOMAN
COULDN'T WIN.
OF COURSE HE IS NOT GOING TO.
THE THIRD THING, THERE WAS A
PRISON IN IOWA THAT WAS QUOTED
THAT I THINK SUMMED UP THIS.
A RANDOM VOTER, BUT THE ISSUE
WITH BERNIE SUPPORTERS IS THAT
THEY GET THE SENSE THAT IT IS
BERNIE OR NO ONE.
BUT WITH BERNIE, THEY BELIEVE
THAT BIGGER COALITION MIGHT HAVE
THE POSSIBILITY AND THE
PROPENSITY TO ACTUALLY GALVANIZE
MORE PEOPLE, AND THEN THAT WILL
GET THEM EVENTUALLY THAT WIN.
THAT IS THE OTHER SIDE OF THAT
COIN.
>> Dana: I THINK THE
BERNIE SANDERS CAMPAIGN HAS A
LOT BETTER ORGANIZATION, BETTER
PEOPLE.
HE SAW JEFF LEAVE HER THERE ON
CAMERA GIVING THE RESPONSE.
YOU DON'T SEE ANY OF THE WARREN
PEOPLE OUT.
>> Juan: ONE LAST THOUGHT IS
THAT THERE WAS SO MUCH HURT LEFT
OVER FROM THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN
IN 2016 AND A LOT OF IT IS STILL
DIRECTED AT BERNIE.
NOT ONLY THE OBAMA PEOPLE NOT
FEEL COMFORTABLE WITH BERNIE,
NEITHER DO THE CLINTON PEOPLE.
YOU'RE STARTING TO SEE THAT COME
OUT NOW.
>> Greg: BUT BERNIE GOT THE
SHORT END OF THE STICK WITH THE
DEBATE, SO HE HAS A REASON TO BE
UPSET.